hey guys i'm maya mitchell and i'm
sierra ramirez
and we are here with buzzfeed we're
gonna be
interviewing each other as super fans of
each other
which we are
what was your first impression of me
when you met me oh my goodness i think
we had our first encounter over twitter
we decided to meet up at a coffee shop
before our first
table read of the fosters everybody's so
nervous like i was so nervous that you
liked me
and instantly it was just like okay bam
that's my sister right there i was
nervous too i was i was freaking out
but you were so sweet oh what is your
favorite cali moment of all time
or acting moment of mine from uh good
trouble old fosters
i mean okay the last one that's a hard
question to ask because i love when you
act i love when you're on my screen
so all of them i think my favorite cali
moments have to be
either when she finally got adopted by
the fosters
or most recently when she passed the bar
i think it's been really fun to see the
growth of cali
and you've grown alongside her and i've
just been like her biggest fan and
rooted for her the whole way and it's
cute to see how she's made her dreams
come true
what is the best night out that we've
ever had together
there's so many we hang out
every weekend um are you sue i mean our
hawaii nights was so fun
hawaii was a great trip we made a dual
music video it was trash
but we loved it when we went to the on
the run tour oh yeah that was the best
night and then we had work at like
five in the morning i had to roll in
there that didn't matter because we saw
beyonce that was a good night
yes oh i love you
what are the ways that i'm most like
callie or
unlike colleen it's kind of weird we've
been having this conversation about how
when you've been playing a character for
so long it kind of
goes hand in hand she's definitely very
strong
and independent just like you and you're
very outspoken you know what you want
you go for it and don't
let anyone stop you also i think style
style wise you'll definitely are very
similar i think she loves
kind of i don't know how to describe it
but like when there's a good thing going
for her
she kind of finds a way to like mess
things up she's pretty self-destructive
a little bit
i don't think that way i think you're
very like you plan out your life and
this is how it's gonna be
but we love her we love her we love her
anyway yeah what about you do you think
that you're
similar to mariana i think so i think we
can both be very stubborn
very sassy and i tend to find myself
like catching myself in real life and
being like ooh
that was a mariana moment mariana's a
compulsive liar though you don't lie
you are like a a compulsive truth teller
exactly it's kind of funny because like
it's like we kind of lie for a living as
actors like i know
i can't lie in real life to save my life
you wouldn't know
no she can't and there's like there's no
no filter
there's nothing you'll know exactly
what's going on
oh what's your favorite song of mine
you know the answer to that i just want
you to love me
i love it maya's always come to visit me
on my sets of my music videos
that's true i stage mom it up i do
because i'm so proud of her
you're so good no i'm i'm so proud of
you i
i love to just come and watch you do
your things i always get to see you
acting and in your element in that way
and to get to see you be creative
in a way that i don't get to usually see
is like so fun
honestly you glow when you're on set and
doing you're
doing your music things like oh i love
it
yeah what's your favorite project that
i've done
outside of good trouble or the faucets
you know i'm i'm a my mitchell fan and
you know
i just seen everything it's between hot
summer nights and never going back you
do love the hot summer nights playlist
though it is a good playlist i listen to
that soundtrack
i loved never going back i thought it
was the most fun
movie if i ever just like need a feel
good moment
i just put it on you watch that movie no
i do
you watch me being a sweaty rat bag
running around
[Laughter]
what would you say is the biggest way
that i've changed or grown
since we first met i mean i met you when
you were 17 and then school
and now you're about to be 26
i think the biggest way is that you've
just
become especially in the past couple
years much more
grounded focused and centered you are
still stubborn but you are not as
stubborn
as you were oh she's growing up
he's growing up honey what's the dumbest
fight we've ever had cece
we've never had like a real fight we
both don't like confrontation
and we tend to keep keep it like to
ourselves until it like kind of bottles
up and like we'll be together and be
like
well this time i feel like this way and
like
you haven't talked to me and it's like
you haven't talked to me and so like
it's just sadly that like it's just like
we don't talk about it and then it's
very cali mariano and it's very
we haven't done that in a while though
we haven't
what is a role you would dream cast me
in dude i want to see you do a musical
so bad you have to do a musical like
7 8 yes oh there it is
exactly what i meant or like a disney
princess i don't know you just need to
do a musical
immediately what about me okay so i was
just
watching i care a lot i haven't seen it
yet i need
a role like that for you something
dramatic like really dark and twisted
and she's like a con
artist and like i just want to see you
be like that like
be a con artist yeah like
i mean yeah it was it's a great movie
you need to watch
what's something that only i know about
you
that people would be surprised to learn
i think i can speak for the both of us
when i say um
something no one knows about us that we
love asmr videos
and pimple popping videos like we went
through a phase where
maya got a follow from dr pimple popper
and it was
a highlight of our day it was and then i
got invited to an event and i felt
embarrassed so i didn't go
oh my goodness you fall asleep to asmr
videos whenever like we have a
sierra you've exposed us we've been
exposed
when did you know that we were going to
be close friends and not just
co-stars i think i always knew that we
were gonna
get along really well i think it wasn't
until
maybe like 2014 we had a couple mutual
friends and we like started to hang out
like outside of work and we would like
run into each other
at like events and like parties and
stuff and then immediately it was just
like
very obvious we were inseparable maybe
like a year into knowing you
yeah i agree didn't take long that was
like what said
seven seven years ago well
we're old what's a job that i would be
good at
if i wasn't an actor i don't know i only
see you as an actor
i know we've both been experiencing what
it's like to executive produce
for the first time i feel like i can
definitely see you
on that side of the camera and i'd love
to see you grow
in that world and i see you directing i
said i only see you in film
it's wild yeah i mean every other job
i've had i was terrible at
elected movie theater i was an usher at
a movie theater i got fired because i
would get so stressed
in the movies and then i watched dishes
for like four years
and i was also really bad at that but it
was my mom's friend's cafe so i couldn't
they couldn't get rid of me that was
very slow
what's the best advice i've ever
convinced i mean you're a little bit
older than me not
not by much but i do look at you as like
an older sister
i've learned a lot about self-worth and
self-love through you
sometimes it's not always what i want to
hear but you know you definitely have
taught me
like what i need to hear and
helps me realize what i deserve and what
my worth is yes
yes what is your favorite mariana moment
of all time
or acting moment of mind because i
didn't ask you i mean there's
just so so many um whenever mariana is
sad
my entire heart breaks it shatters into
a million pieces i can't see mariana
upset
so i feel like in the fosters there were
a lot of like
real big old tearjerker mariana moments
all of your storylines with anna the
birth mom like
flawless you're acting like an
incredible fun fact
sierra can choose which eye to cry out
of
in an exact moment and do a single tear
when you walk out of evan's office and
it's slow motion
and mariana's finally like standing up
for herself
and you know her morals and her values
and like making taking a stand
like that is so powerful i love i love
seeing mariana being
being a boss babe what has been your
proudest
moment of me as my stage mom stage mommy
i remember looking at you when we're at
the premiere of
good trouble season one and we watched
it on like a big screen and we had like
a whole event
and when it popped up like your name is
as an executive producer
i just will never forget that feeling of
how
far and we both come and doing it
together and just
remembering like the 17 year old in the
coffee shop with her dad waiting in the
car outside because he was going to
drive us to the next location
like we're truly like so proud of how
far you've come
and also just like i said seeing you on
on your music video sets and seeing how
much
kind of power you have in that space and
how much agency you have
and uh confidence like i could not do
what you do like it's so vulnerable it's
such a vulnerable thing and seeing you
like owning it is just mind-blowing
well i wouldn't want to do this journey
with anyone but you
me either i love you i love you too okay
now i'm going to cry
i'm like i miss you too
thank you buzzfeed make sure you tune
into good trouble
season three on freeform and hulu
you